il ne reste que ces quelques traces des
voitures incendiées ces derniers jours
dans trois quartiers de la ville si les
habitants sont exaspérés par ces
incivilités
il cherche également à comprendre leurs
auteurs des jeunes qui par manque
d'activité et d'accompagnement tombe
dans la délinquance
ouais c'est déjà les quartiers de france
abschied horaires ne sont pas sortis ils
n'ont pas de parent qui sort hier matin
ils ont tout enlever un appui réel en
pleines vacances scolaires le foyer des
jeunes et les salles de sport sont
fermés un constat que déplore
l'opposition depuis plusieurs années
elles comptent interpeller le maire au
conseil municipal lundi prochain
on est prêt à accompagner nous en tant
que opposition à une démarche et un
travail sur le terrain ça peut aller
bien au delà d'un travail de la majorité
et les associations à mon avis aussi
sont prêtes sur le terrain sauf qu'il
faut faire ce choix
la mairie de son côté se défend
d'abandonner les quartiers énormément de
choses et d'animation qui sont proposées
aux jeunes mâconnais
donc moi je ne peux pas entendre
on ne fait rien pour nos ce matin une
réunion a eu lieu entre le préfet et la
mairie pour décider d'une stratégie
commune
selon le communiqué la présence
renforcée des effectifs de police
nationale est maintenu et des actions
préventives seront organisées dans
chacun des quartiers couple et sa
politique sécuritaire à une politique
sociale
voilà donc le défi que mac qu'on doit
relever